hi hello there internet people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and today
is july 5th 2021 that's right we
celebrated america's birthday
yesterday 245 years strong
love that lady i had just a spectacular
weekend i hope you had a great weekend
and if you're playing along with me
in the reuben report locals community we
get we shared food pictures and
drink pictures and pool pictures and
animal pictures and party pictures
and all sorts of good stuff and videos
and music
and it was nice to be off the main
social media things and just connecting
with actual people so this is just a
special top of the show
shout out to all my reuben report
subscribers it's just nice to see real
people proud of america
and unfortunately our lead story today
will be about
the democrats and they are not proud of
america
uh but before i get into that i just not
only did i have a great weekend but i'm
really really feeling as i said right
before i
uh ended the show on wednesday
was our last show in studio before uh
before the long weekend
um you know i'm feeling just sort of
very appreciative about life
it was my birthday last week obviously
you know people people say nice things
to me and they send me stuff
and all kinds of good stuff and i have
most of the things that i want in life
and i feel good about my work and i'm
growing a company here and a lot of good
stuff and i've got a good team of people
around me and all that
but that really did translate into
yesterday july 4th because
not only did i eat a ton of burgers and
a ton of hot dogs
it was really like a burger hot dog four
day extravaganza i
did a little cardio this morning we're
gonna have to keep working on that and i
think i'm gonna go dry all week
uh but um my niece and nephew were here
and to talk to my niece
about america and about the history of
this place and what
freedom means and had some really
interesting conversations with friends
and family that were visiting
and how everybody at least in my little
world
is feeling this thing like oh maybe we
did
forget a little bit about how important
it is to care about the flag to care
about country
to be patriotic to acknowledge how
wonderful
america is and that's even in my circles
and and i would say even me
myself like all of this stuff it's
cliche but freedom
isn't free and i think in the last you
know year and a half since the lockdowns
began and
and since all of the big tech censorship
has started you know that was really
years before that but just so much
craziness i actually think that people
are waking up and they're going man
maybe
if we are at the end of the road of this
freedom thing if america feels like
the sunset is coming well if there's
something we can do about it we better
do it
so i say all that just to say that i am
going
to continue uh to do the best that i can
to make sure we're not
in that sunset and that the freedom that
people better than me fought for
my grandfathers who both fought in world
war ii and my ancestors before that and
and any of you that are watching that
are servicemen or anyone that
that that does anything to fight these
these awful forces that are here and
just encroaching on our freedoms more
and more
i will do everything i can to to keep
fighting with you and alongside you and
amplify your voices
and all of that good stuff so that's my
little kickoff message
for uh july 5th 2021 we got four stories
for you first off i mean
i wanted to show you a sort of um a
juxtaposition
of a couple democrats tweets about july
4th
mainstream democrats versus a couple
mainstream republican tweets about july
4th because the democrats seem
almost completely unable to say anything
positive about america
that as a general rule but then if they
do say something positive about america
they have to sort of couch it in all of
the negativity
too so we picked a couple democrats and
a couple of republicans and by the way i
asked my guys to look into this before
the fourth because i knew it was coming
it wasn't like yesterday there was a
bunch of bad tweets from democrats and i
was like let's use them
i literally the day before was like guys
keep your eye out because i know what's
going to happen
all the republicans are going to say
nice things about america on july 4th
and let's see what the democrats do
so that's one thing then right before
july 4th the biden administration
tweeted out this ridiculous
image where they're telling people that
uh your fourth of july cook out and
thank and thank you by the way
dementia joe for letting us all have our
small family gatherings uh for july 4th
really appreciative of that by the way
uh but that uh the cost of a july
4th cookout according to the bidet
administration went down
uh from last year you know how much 16
cents and they they actually tweeted
that out
16 says now gas is up we know prices of
everything are up but 16 cents we'll get
into that
then jen saki there i said her name
right okay there you go as you get some
kind of award
remember last week we played this clip
of of her claiming that it's the
republicans that want to
defund the police well now she even
doubled down
even further and she's in essence
saying that joe biden ran on funding the
police
even more okay that was a big piece of
joe biden's campaign
i never heard it we'll get some video on
that and then finally facebook have you
heard
of this giant corporate conglomerate
that's stealing all your information
and uh adding to the political and
cultural chaos in america and all over
the world
they are now giving warnings on content
where you can
actually report your friends and family
for being political extremists
so that's fun too uh so it's gonna be a
big show today
here we go all right i got three tweets
here
from random democrats i said to my guys
let's just find three random democrats
you know well known
but you know somewhat random let's just
pick them and then let's pick a couple
republicans
and let's just juxtapose that's the word
of the day
uh the content in these tweets about
july 4th so
first let's start with aoc from the
hamas caucus aoc
said uh on july 4th going into the woods
for a few days
everyone be good and happy fourth
now first off like stay you know what i
mean stay in the woods
stay as long as you want lady you don't
have to come back
you're not doing anything good you're
not proud of this country
you choked out that everyone be good and
happy for you nothing about being proud
of america
nothing about the freedoms nothing about
the people that have
died for those freedoms nothing pleasant
no flag emojis none of that
she's just going into the woods for a
few days so that's
that's aoc then we've got maxine waters
who's uh as you know
a congresswoman from the los angeles
area who
lives in a 5 million house while she uh
doesn't even live in the place where her
constituents live which is
south central not doing so well she
wrote july 4th
and so the declaration of independence
says all men are created equal
equal to what what men only white men
isn't it something that they wrote in
1776 when african americans
were enslaved they weren't thinking
about us then
but we're thinking about us now this
sort of a historical revisionism is so
deeply dangerous and it's completely
infected the entire democratic party
now it is true slavery existed it's also
true
that we fought a war to end slavery it's
also true that we had a black president
while most european nations
that have existed for hundreds if not
thousands of years longer than us
never had that it is true that we are
now the most equal nation we just are i
know it's scary
to believe that but we just are and it
is also true that many of the men
those white men that were writing
the declaration of independence that
were writing the constitution the
federalist papers all of the
the documents that set us up to be so
free it is true that some of them own
slaves
and some of them were abolitionists and
they were all grappling with all of
those things and some of them
freed their slaves and some of them
didn't free their slaves and all of
those things and they were just
men of their time but they gave us the
words
and the documents to free all the people
so when she says this
when she says this her implication is oh
it's july 4th
america's founding and its founders were
bad
and we are much better and it's like man
maxine waters if you think you are
better
as a human being than the founders of
the united states of america then i i
don't know what you're drinking but i'd
like to try it
corey bush who is a congresswoman from
st
louis missouri this this one wins the
award of the day
she said when they say that the fourth
of july is about american freedom
remember this
the freedom they're referring to is for
white people
this land is stolen land and black
people still aren't free
listen leave corey leave
it's stolen land what are you doing here
right
right i mean if you're saying someone
was here before you
well then go like i've really just had
enough of these people
you can leave and find a better place
that wasn't built on stolen land that
that doesn't have
a complex checkered history and that is
doing more
for everybody like go leave
also there is literally i don't know
that there is anyone
no there might be somebody there might
be a few people who celebrated july 4th
yesterday
and thought boy what a wonderful holiday
july 4th the independence the birthday
of america
were white good for us it's our country
we are white and everyone else will be
subjugated
uh beneath us so when she says they're
referring
to white people no one is no one
conor were you yesterday you had a big
celebration no it wasn't just for white
people michael
a little bit little bit for my do you
see how stupid these people are and
they're actually becoming
a danger a dangerous threat i think to
the republic it's not because she's
saying
go out there and shoot people or calling
for terrorist attacks or something else
but if our political leaders are out
there
basically undermining the entire country
constantly and when we have the days to
celebrate this country one of them wants
to go out to the woods
one of them wants to talk about giving
stolen land back and the other one
waters well actually i can't even get
into water i mean she's just these
people
waters just watch other videos we've
played other videos of waters where
she's instigating violence
get up in their face talking about
republicans and trump supporters
so these are mainstream democrats i
didn't pick just random like out there
democrats cory
cory bush is now like in the squad
situation aoc
is aoc and we all know maxine waters so
then let's pick three comparable
uh republicans and see if there's a
little bit of a difference here's that
juxtaposition word of the day that i
mentioned this is ted cruz
he said happy independence day god bless
america
well that's pretty good that's pretty
good right america got its independence
from great britain and god bless america
we like that guy we have god-given
rights the constitution protects those
rights
zippity-dippity all right america we
like it here's rand paul
he said happy fourth of july today
whether you're on the right the left
or in between let's celebrate and
remember the principles of liberty
that made our country great i think i
dig that one right doesn't matter if
you're on the left
or on the right whatever you are you're
a centrist you're an independent doesn't
matter if you're a republican or a
democrat
like do you dig it do you dig the thing
that we've done here that's pretty
spectacular which is why you never leave
then hey
liberty it's pretty good that's what
made the country great
well done rand paul and then remember
that orange guy donald trump
he's not on twitter anymore because we
have um
tech oligarchs who are more powerful
than the government of the united states
which is
which is a bit of a problem uh even
though i would be leery of an
all-powerful
uh government of the united states uh he
sent out one of his press releases which
was then shared on twitter
he said happy fourth of july to all
do you see a little difference there i
mean these are right like comparable
mainstream people
of course then we have joe biden saying
that you know we're gonna save 16 cents
on our cookout we'll get to that in just
a second
um but i really have been thinking about
this
uh sort of as the backdrop to what i
started the show by saying
which is that i'm really here now to
defend america i think i've been doing
it
for a while but i want to find more and
more of the people who are doing it not
just talking about it and building new
things
but at some point this this idea of sort
of a separation
maybe it is what we need i'm not saying
the united states of america has to
break up
but that we will have parallel economies
to these people like whatever it is
aoc out in the woods wants to build with
maxine waters
and corey bush and all the ideas that
these people want to import that america
is so
fundamentally flawed and evil and it's
built on the backs of slaves and and
that slavery and racism are the prime
pushers of everything american and all
of these things like
i don't really want to it's not that i
don't want to be in a country with those
people
well i know they don't want to be in a
country with me and i don't really want
to be in a country with those people but
my idea of tolerance and my actual old
school liberal values
says that i can live in a society that
it has
people with different values and
different beliefs so the problem is that
i just don't want to
really be doing anything with those
people now they're going to keep putting
in policies to encroach on us right we
talk about this all the time
these guys are always going to put in
policies to take from some to give to
others to rejigger society however they
want to do it
while the rest of us i i really think we
just need to build better things
that are going to have nothing to do
with diversity and inclusion that are
going to have nothing
to do with any of this woke nonsense
that are going to tell a true
honest history of america and that's
really the way we're going to have to go
about
doing those things that's what i'm
trying to build with locals that's what
i'm trying to talk about here
and i think that the next step is
everyone in their own lives
is going to have to do that because what
america what will america look like if
if the corey bush maxine waters aoc
message of what america is and america
was if that wins
let's just extrapolate that five ten
years from now where are we then
where are we then with another five or
ten years worth of young people
who have been brainwashed into thinking
this thing is evil like at some point
someone has to stand up for america and
it can't just be
donald trump right it can't just be uh
people that are going to his rallies
like
maybe america is at the point where
enough of enough things were sold off
there aren't enough people to
to fight for it but i'm going to fight
for it i think you're going to fight for
it we'll see
we'll see so this joe biden guy uh
he is uh i guess the president of the
united states and uh the official white
house
uh twitter account tweeted this out
right before july 4th it's just
quite extraordinary uh planning a
cookout this year
ketchup on the news according to the
farm bureau
the cost of a fourth of july bbq is down
from last year
it's a fact you must herd
hot dog the biden economic plan is
working
and that's something we can all relish
okay i'm not above a bad pun you know it
right like i like a bad pun actually
okay but this is horrible this is just
horrible
and if you look at the image can we put
the image up again for just a sec uh if
you put the image up
uh what they do there they had a gif and
it was flicking through some of the
things and you'd save four cents on this
and five cents on this
the cumulative amount of savings that
they are bragging about
on the official white house twitter
account
from year to year on a july 4th bbq is
cents and someone at the white house got
that information
mr president we've uh crunched the
numbers here uh i used the calculator we
carried the one
and according to this year we've got
great news the economic numbers are in
the average family is going to save 16
cents on their july 4th barbecue and
then someone at the white house
right because it wasn't joe someone at
the white house said tweet that
out tweet out to the good people
that they are going to save 16 cents do
we have 16 cents here either one of you
have changed i haven't had a change in
my pocket
if god knows how long i wish i had a
dime a nickel and a penny
just like just to visually in case you
really can't think with 16 senses we do
everything digitally now
this is so profoundly ridiculous and
it's so
it's so consistent with just how awful
these people are
like everything they say is either a lie
or a manipulation
of truth or they're like
ow somebody you know what
i try not to do it that often but again
i i will go in the comments
of youtube today i will spend a few
minutes with my team after the show
today
i always go into locals i respond to
people but i'm so struck
by this epic load of that the
white house put out
that i will go into the youtube comment
section the most evil place
in the history of the world okay i will
go in there and i want somebody to
explain to me what i'm missing here
how did this happen how did somebody in
the administration say yes
this is a good idea 16 cents even if you
had saved 250
it wouldn't have been a good idea six
dollars it would have been a good idea
relative to the amount of people
that they have caused to be laid off
with lockdowns and put on unemployment
and everything else so no the biden
economic plan
is not working do you think it's working
like do you person
did anyone i saved 16 cents let's buy a
house
me and the little lady we're gonna get a
home loan like come on
jesus let's talk about jen sackey
all right so jen sackey the white house
press secretary
last week she did one of the greatest
gaslights of all time this lady
where she implied that it's the
republicans she said sonny the effect of
some might say it's the republicans
who've been wanting to defund the police
complete and utter nonsensical
well she's continuing her
string of complete and utter nonsensical
at her most recent press conference
where now she's saying that joe biden
ran
on funding the police and law and order
now i have no recollection
and again i will go into the youtube
comment section somebody find me the
video
but that's what she's saying right now i
have no recollection of joe biden ever
saying he wanted to fund the police the
whole
democratic base was calling for defund
the police and we've got the video we're
going to show it to you again
but first here's saki and the president
ran on
most importantly did not run on
defending the police he's always opposed
defunding the police
i'll also note because you've asked this
question before or a few times over the
last several days
that when we talk about individuals
in congress and their support for
funding or
opposition to funding for the police i
think what the american people are most
focused on is how people vote
what their record is which is a public
record and i will note that
while the president ran on and won the
most votes of any candidate in history
in a platform of boosting funding for
law enforcement
after republicans spent decades trying
to cut the cops program
which again is public record we don't
need to uh under
under uh undervalue the intelligence of
the american people
uh the president ran on increasing that
funding it's in his budget
it was in president trump's budget he
significantly
cut that so that's a change
oh i don't like this lady everything she
does
is undervaluing the intelligence of the
american people but let's get the exact
quote
i've got the quote for you that she said
there in case you missed it she said the
president
ran on and won the most votes
of any candidate in the history of the
platform of boosting
funding for law enforcement after
republicans spent
decades trying to cut the cops program
what what are you talking about i have
no recollection i watched
every single debate i am fairly well
versed in the political machinations of
the day i am a man of the media
i have no recollection of biden talking
about boosting policing
complaining that the republicans were
cutting funding for the police i have no
i have no evidence that republicans were
cutting the police anywhere cup
it's been the complete reverse but if
you don't believe me
steve scalise tweeted out this
compilation video it's a little bit
different from the one we showed you
last
week i think you'll enjoy it why use the
word defund why use the word defund yes
i support the defund movement this is
the word that's coming from the street
a growing cry to defund the police
there's some issues that we ask police
to do like mental health issues or
policing in schools and all the rest
that perhaps we can shuffle some of that
money around
we will not be increasing our police
budget we propose
to redirect over seven million dollars
from the police bureau the use of
stormtroopers
under the guise of law and order we've
got to re-examine what we're doing with
american taxpayer dollars
we need to completely dismantle the
minneapolis police department
the minneapolis city council voting nine
to three in favor of disbanding the
police department
today in new york mayor bill de blasio
announced a plan to defund the nypd
i want people to understand that we are
committed to shifting resources
so cities across the country are seeing
a major spike in violent crime now
violent crime is way up and claiming
victims here in los angeles at a rate
we haven't seen in decades crimes
surging in democrat-led
cities that slashed police funding last
year murders up 46
a scary scene earlier this week in new
york city so to shoot out
in the middle of the street during broad
daylight the white house trying to shift
blame because crime is out of control
fighting administration is desperately
trying to spin a new narrative
now it's the republicans who support
defunding the police
democrats embraced this crazy radical
idea of defunding the police last summer
all right so you know that war on
reality i'm always talking about and how
if you have friends and family that
watch cnn and read the new york times
and washington post or whatever else it
is they live in a very different reality
well that's it right there
so perhaps show them that little
two-minute
montage we'll clip it i'll put it on the
twitter
and you can send it to them and then you
can check them into a mental institution
because the cognitive dissonance that
they will have the inability to deal
with reality as it is
not the narrative that they like will
probably snap their brains
and then you know you'll have to visit
them once a week and it's a whole
situation i get it i get it that's why
people don't want to do it
the line that i liked in there though
was nancy pelosi because i did not know
this
storm troopers under the guise of law
and order i mean if we're getting
stormtroopers involved like are we
talking about clone soldiers are we
going back to camino and
making that whole thing happen or are we
going to kidnap children when they're
very young
and turn them into super soldiers you
know
okay you got my point guys uh yeah it's
just a lie saki's a liar
the democrats are liars biden did not
run on boosting funding to the police
and yes it is true that in democrat-run
cities
all hell is breaking loose related to
violence look what's going on in chicago
can we get the numbers from chicago
let's do it it's monday we should have a
fun like
like 70s game show theme song play when
i get this let's get the murders in
chicago today
how many how many it's 80 so there were
i'm guessing shootings not not actual
murders we're going to get the numbers
88 shootings how many were fatal
14 dead 88 shootings this weekend in
chicago
the mayor of chicago by the way is lori
lightfoot
who is the mayor who said that she won't
be interviewed uh
except by black and brown journalists
she also we were going to play the clip
today but we decided not to do it a few
days ago she was interviewed
and she said that 99 of the criticism of
her
is because her critics are racist uh i
am not racist lori lightfoot but you
were an incompetent buffoon and 14
people in your city
died this weekend and 88 were shot so uh
you see you might have a problem there
and it has nothing to do with me being
racist uh
let's move on ah this is it i feel good
about today's show i was a little you
know when
when the show started this morning
because of all the the food and the
drinking and everything else i was like
am i gonna be as sharp
as i'd like to be but i feel that i got
there here we go big finish
uh facebook are you on this thing it was
uh it was a small
website created by this guy mark
zuckerberg
who wanted to meet girls basically about
25 years ago
he created this thing it became sort of
the giant behemoth
of all time next to google let's say and
now it's not just that they can just
delete your account when they want or
they can
limit who sees your account or that they
can shadow ban you and the series of
other things that you guys know about
now they're actually uh going to have a
button
the button is popping up i guess they're
rolling it out in phases although now
people are pushing back so we'll see
what happens
a button so that you'll be able to warn
facebook if you know about people who
are becoming extremists and by
extremists
they mean basically anyone who's not
woke these are images
from disclose dot tv
and uh let's pull these images up are
you concerned that someone you know is
becoming an extremist
we care about preventing extremism on
facebook
others in your situation have received
confidential support
how you can help and then get support or
close and then
here's the other one so carl i'm not
sure who carl is i guess carl works for
disclosed tv carl you may have been
exposed to harmful extremist content
recently
violent groups try to manipulate your
anger and disappointment
you can take action now to protect
yourself and others
now of course because i have a
thoughtful bright
insightful audience you guys already get
what this is about this has nothing to
do
with violent and hateful content because
if it was about violent
content let's say direct calls for
violence direct calls for terrorism
something like that
it would be taken off facebook
immediately but what they're really
doing are you concerned that someone you
know is becoming an extremist what they
mean
really by that is are you concerned that
someone you know might be watching
ben shapiro he talks fast and he says
conservative things
or stephen crowder or dave rubin or
jordan peterson
or something like that i guarantee you
that none of these warnings are being
put
on any woke site those are the real
extremists the ones that are
pushing racism back into the system the
ones that are burning down cities and
defunding the police
and attacking stores and rampaging
through san francisco
and everything else that they're doing
attacking federal buildings in portland
so when they say are you concerned that
someone you know is becoming extremist
what they're saying is are you concerned
that someone you know might be not woke
are you concerned that someone you know
might become a sensible conservative
may not fully accept
all of the blue and odd narrative that's
being forced down everyone's throat
completely i don't like you facebook
you're not good you're not good bad
facebook is bad and the fact that
they're now like i mean this is this is
gen
genuinely this is sort of like out of
communism 101 like
rat on your neighbors this is very
reminiscent actually
of remember at the beginning of lockdown
like when people were calling the cops
on there and my neighbors were in the
backyard
they were playing music they had people
over actually a couple doors down we
have some friends that had a baby and
then they had a baby shower
and the co somebody ratted on them and
the cops came and the cops actually
apologized to them but they said we have
to
we have to actually come here but this
idea will be ratting on each other for
when we get together in real life and
we'll be ratting
on our friends who might be extremists
even though by extremists you probably
mean
sane i mean for example i am a radical
right-wing freedom extremist
i believe in freedom i believe in
liberty i believe that you can make the
choices
for yourself i can make the choices for
myself and we'll negotiate how to go
forward with the society
that's very scary to the people that
want to control you
so thus i am a radical right-wing
extremist
so i assume that these warnings are
going all over your facebook pages
if uh if you follow me but forget about
facebook don't follow me on facebook
join me on locals we are building
something so cool by the way
i'm going back to miami uh later this
week because as you know we moved the
company down there
there is a lot happening
there is a lot happening that's all i
can say for now but i think you guys
know i've been i've been pretty good
about tracking this thing
and every time i've said there's a lot
happening a lot happens and we're
growing real fast
we've got some major partnerships coming
so i'm heading back to miami i may do a
hangout again while i'm down there uh
but we're building something that is the
reverse
of this facebook nonsense so if you
haven't joined us yet
uh check out ruben report.locals.com
where we now have live stream video
i can live stream without big tech just
from my phone from my computer we're
going to have it
the ability to do it from the studio
soon enough uh and on that note
if you have not watched my full
interview with christian angermeier from
atai
sciences who just went to ipo and it's
all about life extension
and psychedelics and depression and just
other ways
of dealing with the crazy world that
we're in i think you will dig it so you
can get that full on youtube
uh and then tomorrow i'm interviewing jd
vance the
author and political pundit uh hillbilly
elegy
and uh let's see and we'll have a clip
up tomorrow oh yeah
okay oh no i'm sorry we're off by a day
here uh clip one
will be on wednesday i'm interviewing
him actually tomorrow but clip one will
be on wednesday
and also he just invested with peter
thiel in rumble
which is a youtube competitor which is
seriously interesting
i think he's about to announce a senate
run it is is it announced
it is announced already he already
announced the senate run so i'm really
looking forward to
talking to him and uh all right that's
about it
as i said if you want you want to chat
with me see what's up and
you know find other human beings that
aren't completely insane join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
as i said i will jump in the youtube
comment section today
because if you could prove me wrong on
some of the things i said
i'd like to know about it that's it
happy birthday america have a great day
everybody
big week let's keep going that's all see
ya